les jardins une passion française une
série qui tout au long de cette semaine
va nous entraîner dans les plus beaux
parcs et jardins de france et puis aussi
d'europe
commençons donc par pari par les buttes
chaumont et ses 25 hectares ce jardin
était composé au début du 20e siècle
pour permettre aux parisiens les moins
riches de changer d'air on y vient un
pique-niqué faire du sport et il faut
savoir que les buttes chaumont que les
buttes chaumont sont un lieu privilégié
des photographes spécialisés dans les
photos de mariage et ving holman daniel
levy le samedi matin dès qu'il fait beau
les buttes chaumont se transforme en
gigantesque studio photographique bien
on me regarde
l'an prochain
photo à la chaîne les mariés venus d'un
peu partout se comptent par dizaines
chaque couple a l'impression d'être
unique
il s'agit d'abord d'immortaliser cet
événement inoubliable
un vrai régal pour le promeneur car ici
le spectacle est permanent
ça fait penser à mon temps de revenir
aussi regarder ces mariages et la chaîne
le samedi parce que il ya un mélange de
cultures et conan la concurrence fait
rage pas un endroit du parc qu'ils ne
soient pris d'assaut pour les clichés
pont suspendu bord du lac avec fond de
falaise pelouse verte parterres de
fleurs décor idéal pour l'imagerie
romantique mais dix sept aux sportifs
d'entrer en scène
le parc est très dénivelé il faut de
l'entraînement pour en profiter ce n'est
pas le cas tout le monde avec grand
parcours mais ça manque de trop j'essaie
échouant face à un possible
trop dur c'est l'heure du déjeuner un
des rares parcs de paris où l'on peut
pique-niquer quand il fait beau c'est
comme si on était un peu en vacances la
plage à deux pas de chez soi
le dépaysement assuré c'est naturel par
rapport aux attendra de paris l'a fait
un peu sauvage avec les rushs ce
sentiment de la nature c'est bien ce que
voulaient les paysagistes
il y a près dé 200 ans leur objectif
faire oublier la cité à ses habitants en
imitant différents paysages de france
comme les falaises d'étretat tout cela
disparaît un peu aujourd'hui sous la
végétation
mais pour le visiteur le sentiment de la
nature est encore bien vivant